oi galera ai galera aí que assistiu a
tudo com vocês
então quem me acompanha no facebook me
acompanha no twitter sabe que eu sou uma
pessoa pouco noturno ele que comecei
então a internet nesse negócio de ficar
sempre atualizando sempre pode ter
alguma coisa pra galera tá olhando eu
comecei a minha pessoa não tocar isso me
complica muito porque porque às vezes eu
tenho um compromisso de manhã e eu como
eu fico até muito tarde na internet eu
vou dormir muito tarde e aí eu aposto
muito tá outro dia 6 foi dormir seis
horas da manhã quando de hotéis hora da
madrugada tinha um ônibus usando aqui na
frente da minha casa já que é um
desrespeito com minoritários que são
desrespeito o pior não é você dormir
tarde e acordar sido pior você tentar
dormir cedo e não consegui um absurdo
ver comigo sabe quando você tá começando
a dormir você encontra aquela posição
perfeita aquela posição que parece que
você nasceu pra nome nela a ligar aquela
posição paz que deus quer assim a você e
você nasceu pra dormir assim é uma vez
no ano que você encontra essa posição
perfeita para mim é que você finalmente
encontra se já está quase domingo
enviada à corda mas não daquela página
do bichinho tinha um bolso de trás e
gozo por já falei que aquela 12 legal e
só 3 de abril falou
aí pronto você acorda e não consegue
encontrar uma desgraça naquela posição
tem também aquela que você dá um cd mais
é você acorda de noite ainda acham que
já é outro dia a dia da equipe ontem não
foi um momento da vida da gente que a
gente mais consegue dormir rápido sala
de aula e amigos e pode tomar 50 lakic
red bull professor falando vamos abrir o
livro na página 17 beleza né pessoal 17
eu achei engraçado que a madeira da
carteira vira ortobom na mesma hora você
dorme com a beleza levanta dizer que
todo roxo da pesca zona da mata então
essa é a solução de dormir cedo por
exemplo pode dormir pensando em uma
história só que como tudo tem um lado
ruim
isso também tem um lado ruim para o
sonho que era tirar isso aí você também
pode dormir pensando nela que mais lhe
dar só ontem matemática mas a matemática
pode fazer um negócio um pouco diferente
mas acho que você ganhou na mega da
virada é isso que fazemos cálculo
daquele que você vai comprar com o
dinheiro vai ser minha 150 milhões de
reais para comprar casa ou para um bar
popular ocupam um é o trauma é comprar
um monte de coisa pela mãe de coisa com
procura anita época
só que como eu falei tudo tomado muito
[ __ ] que pariu tinha acabado de comprar
xbox lê droga mas funciona comigo eu
consigo dormir desse jeito e é isso aí
tem um amigo que fica por apertar com
você nesse vídeo pra ele eu já falei
você gostou do vídeo clique aqui não
gostei você me ajuda a crescer meu
trabalho que já falei um milhão de vezes
vou falar de novo com um pano de crescer
o canal comprar outras câmeras e outros
equipamentos ea loja unik importa está
me ajudando nisso tem um link na
descrição do vídeo vai abrir um site só
clicar neste link você já tá me ajudando
eles vão saber que eu faço no meu vídeo
ele foi lá então clique aqui para ir no
site deles pra você me ajudar também a
manter o canal tal muito obrigado por
ter assistir esse vídeo até aqui
e foi foi passa o caminhão na hora da
mensagem essa razão pra cantar a música
pra você no mito uma nos cansamos lapada
na rachada e pede que eu te dou lá para
quem nasceu pra ser co nunca vai ser ter
cá
[Música]
eu nem ninguém
nem benfica nem ciro eu te amo amar te
amo te amo te amo te meteu o meu porque
[Música]
o meu carro tinha um show
sinto sujo do boom guarde mata
[Música]